[Applause]
they represent a fairly small sector of
airport workers but if you can't pass
through security you can't fly Germany's
latest industrial dispute a walk out by
security screeners therefore crippling
affected airports some of the country's
major ones Berlin Hamburg stutgart
canceled all departures grounding around
200,000 passengers many tourists and not
all of them warned in advance I talk
yesterday with my Turkish Airlines and
flight members but nobody confir they
have no idea the information on email or
I don't know
nothing the one-day strike is part of a
recent Spate of industrial action until
now rare in Germany where workplace
relations have tended to be more
constructive than elsewhere in Europe
Now High inflation and a shortage of
skilled workers have given unions the
upper hand in demanding better wages and
conditions when the employer don't get
our uh solution we strike again again
again it comes at a bad time for
Germany's stagnant economy now we see
that systematically these strikes become
longer and more frequent and then the
economic costs are going to rise
significantly and um this comes on the
back of an economy that is already weak
the German economy has been shrinking
last year is barely growing this year so
this strike comes at the wrong time for
the German
economy there was some relief for
travelers this week as train drivers
returned to work on Monday but Tuesday
saw thousands of doctors on strike and
on Friday it'll be the turn of public
transport workers bringing trams Subways
and buses to a halt jahal Al jazer